Pero por el momento, ya que no se ha encontrado
evidencia de nuevos fenómenos, esto nos deja suponer
que las partículas que conocemos hoy en día,
incluyendo el bosón de Higgs,
son las únicas partículas elementales en la naturaleza,
incluso a energías mucho mayores
que las que hemos explorado hasta ahora.
Vamos a ver a donde nos llevará esta hipótesis.
Nos encontraremos con un resultado sorprendente y fascinante
acerca de nuestro universo; y para explicar mi punto,
primero les explicaré qué es el Higgs,
y para hacerlo, tenemos que retroceder
a un diezmilmillonésimo de segundo
después del Big Bang.
Y según la teoría de Higgs,
en ese instante, se produjo un acontecimiento dramático
en el universo.
El espacio-tiempo experimentó una transición de fase.
Fue algo muy similar a la transición de fase
que ocurre cuando el agua se convierte en hielo
por debajo de los cero grados.
Pero en nuestro caso, la transición de fase
no es un cambio en la forma como las moléculas
se organizan dentro de la materia,
sino que se trata de un cambio
de la estructura del espacio-tiempo.
Durante esta transición de fase, el espacio vacío
se llenó de una sustancia
que ahora llamamos campo de Higgs.
Y esta sustancia puede parecer invisible para nosotros,
pero tiene una realidad física.
Nos rodea todo el tiempo,
al igual que el aire que respiramos en esta habitación.
Y algunas partículas elementales interactúan
con esta sustancia, obteniendo energía en el proceso.
Y esta energía intrínseca es lo que llamamos
la masa de una partícula,
y al descubrir el bosón de Higgs, el GCH
ha demostrado concluyentemente que esta sustancia es real,
porque las cosas están constituidas por los bosones de Higgs.
Y esto, en pocas palabras, es la esencia de la historia de Higgs.
Pero esta historia es mucho más interesante.
Mediante el estudio de la teoría de Higgs,
físicos teóricos descubrieron,
no a través de un experimento
sino mediante el poder de las matemáticas,
que el campo de Higgs no existe necesariamente
solamente en la forma que observamos hoy.
Al igual que la materia puede existir como líquido o sólido,
el campo de Higgs, la sustancia que llena todo el espacio-tiempo,
podría existir en dos estados.
Además el estado de Higgs conocido,
podría haber adoptado un segundo estado donde el campo de Higgs
es miles de millones de veces más denso
que lo que observamos hoy en día,
y la mera existencia de otro estado
del campo de Higgs plantea un problema potencial.
Esto es porque, de acuerdo a las leyes
de la mecánica cuántica, es posible
tener transiciones entre dos estados,
incluso en presencia de una barrera de energía
que separe los dos estados,
un fenómeno llamado,
muy apropiadamente, efecto túnel cuántico.
Debido al efecto túnel cuántico
yo podría desaparecer de esta habitación
y aparecer en la habitación de al lado,
prácticamente penetrando la pared.
Pero no esperen que realice el truco
ante sus ojos, porque la probabilidad
para mí de atravesar la pared es ridículamente pequeña.
Tendrán que esperar mucho tiempo
antes de que suceda, pero créanme,
el efecto túnel cuántico es un fenómeno real,
y se ha observado en muchos sistemas.
Por ejemplo, el diodo túnel,
un componente usado en electrónica,
funciona gracias a las maravillas
del efecto túnel cuántico.
Pero volvamos al campo de Higgs.
Si existiera el estado Higgs ultra denso,
entonces, debido al efecto túnel cuántico,
una burbuja de este estado podría aparecer de repente
en algún lugar del universo en un momento determinado,
lo que es análogo a lo que sucede cuando el agua hierve.
Las burbujas de vapor se forman dentro del agua,
luego se expanden, convirtiendo líquido en gas.
De la misma manera, una burbuja del estado Higgs ultra denso
podría venir a la existencia por el efecto túnel cuántico.
Luego se expandiría la burbuja a la velocidad de la luz,
invadiendo todo el espacio y convirtiendo el campo de Higgs
del estado familiar al nuevo estado.
¿Esto es un problema? Sí, es un gran problema.
No puede ocurrirnos en la vida cotidiana,
pero la intensidad del campo de Higgs es crítica
para la estructura de la materia.
Si el campo de Higgs fuera un poco más intenso,
veríamos átomos encogiéndose, neutrones decayendo
dentro de los núcleos atómicos, los núcleos desintegrándose,
y el hidrógeno sería
el único elemento químico posible en el universo.
El campo de Higgs, en su estado de Higgs ultra denso,
no solo es un par de veces más intenso que en la actualidad,
sino miles de millones de veces,
y si el espacio-tiempo se llenara con ese estado de Higgs,
toda la materia atómica colapsaría.
No existirían estructuras moleculares, ni vida.
Entonces, me pregunto, ¿es posible
que en el futuro, el campo de Higgs
sufra una transición de fase y,
a través del efecto túnel cuántico, se transforme
en este estado desagradable, ultra denso?
En otras palabras, me pregunto, ¿cuál es el destino
del campo de Higgs en nuestro universo?
Y el ingrediente crucial necesario
para responder a esta pregunta es la masa del bosón de Higgs.
Y experimentos en el GCH encontraron que la masa
del bosón de Higgs es aproximadamente 126 GeV.
Esto es pequeño cuando se expresa en unidades familiares,
porque es igual
a 10 a la menos 22 gramos.
Pero es grande en las unidades de la física de partículas,
porque es igual al peso
de una molécula entera
de un constituyente del ADN.
Armados con esta información del GCH,
junto con algunos colegas aquí en el CERN,
calculamos la probabilidad
de que nuestro universo pudiera atravesar el túnel cuántico
al estado de Higgs ultra denso,
y hemos encontrado un resultado muy interesante.
Nuestros cálculos han demostrado
que el valor medido de la masa de bosón de Higgs
es muy especial.
Tiene justo el valor correcto
para mantener suspendido al universo
en una situación inestable.
El campo de Higgs está en una configuración inestable
que se ha mantenido hasta ahora
pero que finalmente se derrumbará.
Así que según estos cálculos,
somos como los campistas
que accidentalmente ponen su tienda
en el borde de un precipicio.
Y finalmente, el campo de Higgs
experimentará una transición de fase
y la materia se derrumbará en sí misma.
¿Así es cómo la humanidad va a desaparecer?
No lo creo.
Nuestro cálculo muestra que ese efecto túnel cuántico
del campo de Higgs no es probable que se produzca
en los próximos 10 a la 100 años
y eso es mucho tiempo.
Es incluso más
que el tiempo que tarda Italia en formar un gobierno estable.
(Risas)
Aún así, para entonces ya nos habremos ido hace tiempo.
En unos 5 mil millones de años,
nuestro Sol se convertirá en una gigante roja,
tan grande como la órbita de la Tierra,
y nuestra Tierra será "kaput",
y en un billón de años,
si la energía oscura sigue impulsando
la expansión del espacio al ritmo actual,
ni siquiera podrán ver más allá de sus pies,
porque todo a su alrededor
se expandirá a un ritmo más rápido que la velocidad de la luz.
Así que es muy poco probable
que estemos por allí para ver el colapso del campo de Higgs.
Pero la razón para interesarme
en la transición del campo de Higgs
es porque quiero abordar la cuestión,
¿por qué es la masa del bosón de Higgs tan especial?
¿Por qué es justo la correcta para mantener el universo
en el borde de una transición de fase?
Los físicos teóricos siempre preguntan "por qué".
Mucho más que "cómo" funciona un fenómeno,
los físicos teóricos siempre están interesados en
"por qué" un fenómeno funciona de la manera que funciona.
Creemos que estas preguntas de "por qué"
nos pueden dar pistas
acerca de los principios fundamentales de la naturaleza.
Y en efecto, una posible respuesta a mi pregunta
abre nuevos universos, literalmente.
Se ha especulado que nuestro universo
es solo una burbuja en un multiverso jabonoso
hecho de una multitud de burbujas,
y cada burbuja es un universo diferente
con diferentes constantes fundamentales
y diferentes leyes físicas.
Y en este contexto, solo se puede hablar de
la probabilidad de encontrar un determinado valor de la masa de Higgs.
Entonces la clave del misterio
podría residir en las propiedades estadísticas
del multiverso.
Sería algo parecido a lo que sucede
con las dunas de arena en una playa.
En principio, uno podría imaginar encontrar dunas de arena
con cualquier ángulo de pendiente en una playa,
y sin embargo, los ángulos de inclinación de las dunas de arena
típicamente miden alrededor de 30, 35 grados.
Y la razón es simple:
el viento acumula la arena y la gravedad la hace caer.
Como resultado, la mayoría de las dunas de arena
tienen ángulos de inclinación alrededor del valor crítico,
cerca del colapso.
Y algo similar podría suceder
para la masa del bosón de Higgs en el multiverso.
En la mayoría de los universos burbuja,
la masa de Higgs podría estar alrededor del valor crítico,
cerca de un colapso cósmico del campo de Higgs,
debido a dos efectos en competencia,
igual que en el caso de la arena.
Mi historia no tiene un fin,
porque aún no sabemos el final de la historia.
Esto es ciencia en progreso,
y para resolver el misterio, necesitamos más datos,
y espero que el GCH pronto añada nuevas pistas
a esta historia.
Solo un número, la masa del bosón de Higgs,
y sin embargo, de este número aprendemos mucho.
Yo empecé desde una hipótesis, que las partículas conocidas
son todo lo que hay en el universo,
incluso más allá del dominio explorado hasta ahora.
De esto, descubrimos que el campo de Higgs
que impregna el espacio-tiempo puede estar permanentemente
al filo de la navaja, listo para el colapso cósmico,
y descubrimos que esta puede ser una pista de
que nuestro universo es solo un grano de arena
en una playa gigante, el multiverso.
Pero no sé si mi hipótesis es correcta.
Así es como funciona la física: una sola medición
puede ponernos en el camino a una nueva comprensión
del universo
o nos puede enviar a un callejón sin salida.
Pero en cualquier caso
de una cosa estoy seguro:
El viaje estará lleno de sorpresas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)